the movie starts in a diner where a
single mother nina harrison is having
breakfast with her only son dorian nina
takes out her old camcorder and starts
taking videos of dorian as it is his
first day of college as dorian is busy
listening to his mother he accidentally
squirts some ketchup on his shirt hence
he tells his mom to start recording
again shockingly when she presses the
rewind button on the camcorder
everything around her goes back in time
as if she has found a glitch in the
matrix
the incident leaves nina speechless and
she starts breathing heavily but just as
the previous incidents are about to
repeat themselves she quickly stops her
son from squirting the ketchup again she
then asks him about the stain on his
shirt but as expected dorian doesn't
remember it and simply acts confused as
a result nina also assumes that she just
experienced deja vu and the two continue
with their day next the two hit the road
and proceed towards dorian's new school
as dorian is driving he takes out the
camcorder and starts recording in the
heat of the moment he also crosses the
speed limit unfortunately their fun
moment comes to an end when a police car
begins pursuing them nina asks her son
to pull over and so he does at first the
officer lasky taunts them for being
black and then inquires if they have any
guns with them dorian who is clearly
agitated by the racist remarks tries to
speak back but his mother calms him down
however the officer keeps provoking them
just then he notices the camcorder still
in recording mode and angrily asks nina
to turn it off dorian tells him that
they have the right to record but lasky
forcefully tries to grab it during the
tussle nina presses the rewind button
accidentally and as soon as she does so
the time rewinds and the two are taken
back to five minutes in the past where
the officer hasn't yet approached them
even this time nina feels terribly tired
as if the time jump has drained her of
her energy seeing her dorian gets
worried and pulls over at the same
location as before as he tries to
comfort his mother officer lasky
approaches them again although the
harrisons haven't done anything wrong
this time he still manages to bring up
an excuse to humiliate them lasky
mentions that a small part of the car is
still touching the road which is a
violation of law when someone pulls over
hearing this dorian gets angry as his
mom is in serious need of help he
confronts the officer saying that they
have bigger things to worry about but
lasky is adamant on punishing them when
dorian doesn't back off lasky brings out
his gun and prepares to shoot
fortunately nina who is still holding
the camera presses the rewind button
again and saves them from the situation
this time she presses the button long
enough to take them back to the diner it
turns out that lasky has been in the
same diner with them since the very
first scene and this is where he starts
targeting them over and over again
because of his racist nature realizing
that her son's life is in danger nina
immediately leaves with him and this
time she takes the wheel she also takes
the long way hoping that they will
finally evade the racist cop expectedly
dorian is left confused by the sudden
change in his mother's behavior but she
assures him that everything is fine the
duo then starts bonding over a song and
decides to skip school so that they can
spend some time together later they
arrive at a motel and plan to eat junk
food on the tv nina watches a lottery
show and thinks of a plan at first she
secretly records the numbers being drawn
then she comments on how foolish the
lottery is but dorian feels it's not all
completely random he believes in
predestination and the theory that if
something should happen it will happen
meanwhile nina presses the rewind button
but only long enough to go back in time
before the lottery numbers are called
she then accurately calls the numbers
leaving her sons stunned she also
promises to win the lottery for them
just when nina assumes that they have
finally averted the danger a sudden
knock on the door stuns her when dorian
opens the door her worst fears come true
officer lasky has again followed them
and this time he mentions that he got a
noise complaint call weirdly he assumes
the mom son duo are a couple and asks
them to bring out their identities and
once again dorian becomes angry as they
have done nothing wrong he tries to make
the cop leave but just then the latter
notices the camcorder in nina's hands
lasky then tries barging into the
apartment and a tussle ensues between
him and dorian as nina watches in horror
the racist cop smacks her son's head
into a nearby glass frame and prepares
to shoot but before he can do so nina
rewinds the time and takes them back to
the diner this time she realizes that no
matter where she hides the officer like
some kind of racist agent smith will
manage to find them it seems as if the
matrix has destined the harrisons to be
apprehended by the racist cop hence nina
attempts to try something new and leaves
her table to interact with lasky her
plan is to win the officer's trust by
initiating a conversation at first she
introduces herself and buys a pie for
him mentioning that she is indebted
towards his services for the country he
accepts her kindness but insists that he
does not know her so in order to gain
his trust further nina starts explaining
that her son means everything to her and
that he is going to college today then
she asks about his family and the
officer emotionally replies that his
wife passed away several years earlier
and that life has been hard for him ever
since hearing this nina offers her
condolences and an appreciative lasky
thanks her for the pie and gets up but
before nina can leave he notices her car
and inquires if she bought it herself
nina replies that she worked very hard
for it but lasky orders her to bring out
the car ownership and registration
papers as soon as nina hears this she
loses her temper and starts shouting
that she doesn't need to show any of
those papers dorian tries calming his
mother down but she doesn't listen left
with no choice he enters the car to
retrieve his phone as he had clicked a
picture of the registration papers
earlier however as soon as he brings out
his phone the cop mistakes it for
something else and shoots him right
through the chest without any hesitation
dorian dies immediately and witnessing
this a devastated nina drops her
camcorder on the floor in the next scene
nina is at the hospital where she has
been called to identify her son's body
once all the formalities are done nina
asks the head doctor about her camcorder
which was with her during the incident
shortly after nina gets her camcorder
back but before she presses the rewind
button she prays to god that it works
fortunately it does and once again
everything rewinds back to the diner
scene nina is delighted to see her son
alive and well and hugs him immediately
now after learning her lesson several
times she decides to leave the diner
immediately before officer lasky even
arrives however while heading out they
come across the officer but he simply
opens the door for them later nina parks
near an abandoned house and finally
reveals everything to her son she
mentions that the camcorder has
supernatural abilities with the help of
which they can rewind back in time she
also talks about the racist officer and
how he keeps following them everywhere
they go she then pleads with dorian to
help her find a way to break the loop
dorian knows that his mother is not
lying so he starts brainstorming ideas
after a bit of thinking an idea finally
strikes his mind and he suggests they
quickly deviate from the path by going
to his uncle's house after a while they
reach a neighborhood which appears to be
the place nina was raised in there she
tells dorian how her older brothers were
shot dead by police officers and how the
incident has left her traumatized ever
since soon they are greeted by her older
brother neil who still lives there but
the two appear to be cold towards one
another it turns out that he is still
upset that she didn't come to their
father's funeral however on seeing his
sister in bad condition neil takes the
mom's son duo inside there nina explains
everything to her estranged brother and
asks for his help to stop officer lasky
she tries her best to make him
understand that she is not lying and
surprisingly neil being a loyal brother
and a strong supporter of movements like
black lives matter instantly believes
her it is then revealed that the
camcorder previously belonged to their
father before he passed it to nina
moreover neil reveals that their father
always told stories of magic like this
perhaps even he used the camcorder
several times to save them from messy
situations with this knowledge the
brother sister duo finally reconciles
and hugs one another that night the
three gather around and start making
elaborate plans to stop the inevitable
neil proposes that they take dorian to
college as it is the only place other
people can help them it turns out that
dorian is admitted to an all-black
college so if lasky tries harassing them
there the others will revolt but first
they have to get to the college which is
very risky by road hence neil plans out
a shortcut route for dorian to make it
to the school unnoticed he uses personal
blueprints of the town he has designed
over the years in the next scene neil
leads them inside an underground tunnel
which he claims was used several decades
ago as a mining base along the way nina
and neil reminisce about their childhood
days and also about their late father
shortly after they climb outside of the
tunnel which leads them right to the
college dorian is elated to see so many
students there and can't wait to
interact with them however as the three
continue proceeding towards the entrance
the villain officer lasky appears out of
nowhere he orders them to stop and
inquires about what they were doing
inside the tunnel scared nina tries
taking her son away but the officer
takes out his gun and points it at them
seeing this neil puts himself in harm's
way and dares the officer to shoot at
the same time some other police officers
arrive at the scene with their guns fed
up with the injustice and discrimination
she has faced from lasky nina steps
forward with her camcorder and starts
recording the cops dorian tells her to
press the rewind button and restart
everything but this time she refuses
instead she locks the camcorder and now
there is no going back seeing her
courage the other students in the
college also bring out their cell phones
and start recording the incident at
first lasky laughs at the idea of being
intimidated by a camcorder however with
everyone's attention on her nina starts
speaking she berates lasky for abusing
his authority and harassing others just
because of their skin color she also
calls him out for being a corrupt
officer who only cares about himself and
not the welfare of other people
realizing that they are fighting a
losing battle the other cops back off
and proceed towards their cars but lasky
is still adamant on teaching nina a
lesson he prepares to fire his gun and
settle the matter once and for all but
when he glances around and sees all the
students with their cameras out he
becomes scared and lowers his gun as he
walks away nina taunts him for being a
loser in this way the harrisons with the
help of neil and a bunch of students
finally end the loop they were trapped
in cut to several years later dorian has
now become a father and has managed to
do well with his life as he plays with
his daughter nina records them joyfully
with the same recorder just then the
little girl takes the camcorder and
accidentally drops it to the ground
breaking it into pieces witnessing this
a devastated nina quickly rushes to the
pieces as the device had always been
with her through thick and thin she had
become so used to it that it had started
affecting her normal life as she weeps
in despair dorian helps her up and urges
her to move on he tells her that now
they can make real memories without
having to depend on a device the movie
ends as nina starts a new journey in her
life one without the camcorder that had
saved her several times in the past
however when the scene fades black
police sirens are heard indicating that
she has to deal with the officer once
again but this time with no rewind
option the moral of the story is that
you can't cure racism with pie
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching